véronique sanson tu sort un nouvel album
c'est le neuvième ça s'appelle mois le
zona c'est ça est ce que tu as déjà
réfléchi est-ce que tu allais dire pour
les télévisions il fallait être invité
non mais enfin tu vas me fournir
l'occasion je sais pas par exemple si je
te dis tu as une minute pour me le
vendre dès ce que je te dis qu'il est
formidable c'est bien et que j'ai mis
longtemps à le faire que vous voyez que
c'est bien timidement mais
je l'aurais jamais ça c'est un argument
tu le vois stephen stills encore will
champion aux touts les femmes bien sûr
c'est le père de mon fils et je le vois
wyss toi est ce qui fait en ce moment la
scala ou deux pour malte on est vraiment
et puis maintenant à bord ils ont tout
ça et maintenant ils sont tous ralliés
tournée we kreia et font ils font plus
en meilleure forme que jamais et je
crois qu'ils vont sortir un jeu c'est
qu'ils sortent un livre qui prendrait si
le zonage n y en avait pas fait plus
trop comment s'y trouvent à comment ce
qui est très très beau dire mais quand
tu seras plus âgés tu continueras à te
montrer où tu écriras pour les autres on
tente avant je suis très bien à gand
longtemps je sais pas non plus être pas
le pas et fait craindre pour les autres
ouais je prends devient un des shows ou
j'écrirai des livres de cuisine chez
thecus chaude
sipa les listings par exemple qui sera
pour quoi je parle je ferai ça c'est une
chose que je ferais bien sûr son
programme à notre disposition des moyens
formidables pour retarder les les
le vieillissement et reconcentre fait
mieux dans sa troupe si on se sent d'ici
on est beaux châteaux que son duo là là
je peux pas aller je ne peux pas être
beau être complexe pas d'accord j'étais
prêt si on peut le faire il faut le
faire c'est cigale ou fourmi italie du
pognon de côté pendant les années fastes
je ne sais pas c'est pas moi qui m'en
occupe
mais j'espère de tous ces mois ci c'est
confiance c'est quelqu'un qui avait un
abcès rim quelques jours tu veux lui
dire maintenant je m'arrête je me retire
je vais en grèce je vais en espagne à
bull de l'afrique
s'ils veulent te dire va pas amener peut
pas annuler hier l'open ont arrêté un
prêt si on est sûr entendu parler des
questions qu'ont les questions qu'ont
souvent